instead of reporting the width in the
number of physical Hardware pixels the
browser reports the width in the number
of dips or device-independent pixels as
its name implies a device independent
pixel is a unit of measurement that
actually relates pixels to a real
distance the idea being that a device
independent pixel will take up the same
amount of space on a display regardless
of the pixel density of the display so
if there are twice as many Hardware
pixels across as there are pixels
reported by the browser the Chromebook
pixel must have a device pixel ratio of
two right the browser has a viewport
width of twelve hundred and eighty dips
the twelve hundred and eighty dips gets
scaled up to twenty five hundred and
sixty Hardware pixels when the page is
rendered on the display back to my
unoptimized website what's the browser
doing when the viewport isn't set unless
you tell the browser that your site was
designed to work on a small screen it
assumes that they weren't and renders
the page as if it were on a screen that
were 980 dips wide now imagine that
content being scaled to fit on a phone
that's only 360 dips wide it gets scaled
to less than half yuck it then tries to
make the content look better by doing
something called font boosting the
browser tries to pick the primary
content on the page and scale it up oh
wait a second it's another browser is
actually trying to guess at what content
is important this sounds like a problem
yep that means that some fonts are large
and easy to read while others remain
small and are really hard to read users
will have to spend a lot of time
pinching to zoom in order to see and
interact with the content that is not
ideal nope